alors il ya un candidat qui vous a pas
échappé c'est sébastien auger qui était
un candidat qui a un restaurant je crois
en belgique qui est apparu quelque peu
quelque peu arrogant et insolents on va
aller les images on en parle juste après
la base ma formation j'ai fait que des
étonné j'ai une grosse clientèle de los
angeles hong kong
j'ai déjà série vivier en fait en
réalité j'ai pas de point faible il faut
mélanger fille que je te laisse et jean
françois piège et c'est moi geoffrey
jamais les choses à moitié quand vous
serez surpris par le plein d'or fait
goûter bon là je suis sûr c'est donc le
petit sébastien va sûrement dépassée
tout le monde va on va voir comment ça
va se dérouler sa part à tête très haute
et je suis plus que content de ce que
j'ai pu faire et donc il n'ya pas ok
j'ai aucun regret et là il a réagi sur
les réseaux alors quand même je vous
précisons qu'on l'a on qu'on a invité
aujourd'hui pour qu'il puisse répondre à
ce qu'on les dit de lui et les parties
blanc il est tellement été attaqué sur
les sur les réseaux qui a souhaité vous
les regardez totalement disparaître et
il a déclaré le montage réalisé par la
production ne correspond pas du tout à
ce que je suis dans la réalité les gens
qui me connaissent s'en rendre compte
tous peut tout de suite compte je ne
suis pas du tout quelqu'un de
prétentieux il dit tout ça mais s'est
accrue parce qu'il sera maintenant
rendre de l'impact
allez-y soit la chaîne une phrase
[Rires]
constamment ce pauvre ce garçon yann je
sais pas combien de candidats et les 14
candidats on monte toujours le même
donc effectivement qui a un effet miroir
complètement sur lui et qui réagit et en
revanche quelle que soit la chaîne on ne
mesure jamais l'impact de ce qu'on dise
surtout quand sans le ou canton le
montrer leur monde ces accusations sont
graves
benjamin quand même pas ce qui dit il
dit qu'on l'a fait passer pour ce qu'il
n'est pas on a presque détruit sa
réputation et sa carrière
moi quand j'ai vu l'émission je me suis
dit il a été éliminé jamais je n'irai
dans le restaurant que ces gars-là
désastre aurait absolument
donc si c'est faux c'est très grave pour
lui franchement arrêtons dernièrement
dernièrement venu dernièrement sûreté
pmp vous aviez invité
des candidats de top chef mais eux-mêmes
disait que la prod demandait de faire
certaines choses faire le remake donc
moi je quand j'entends ce qu'il dit je
n'ai pas trop envie de mettre sa parole
en doute jeune homme va y avoir un bébé
avec benayoun la main on attend qu'on
nous parle alors pour tester faire alors
de l'ormeau alesi calmement
merci ouais parce que tu as vu quand
elle parle à ma main et tout ça n'est
jamais jamais arrivé je connais bien
rotenberg et toute cette prod ça n'est
jamais arrivé que d'une personne qui
soit un argent n'a pas ça oui mais bon
voilà
non je suis désolé cette personne doit
être un peu arrogant même chose mais fin
mai au 8 ème avec en français autre
séquence qui a fait polémique
il y avait une épreuve de la dernière
chance oui et qui devait récupérer l'un
des cuisiniers et il ya un dessert en
forme d'ananas qui a fait polémique
c'est vrai que globalement compteront
choix ne s'est pas au regard des nazis
toria sauce crémeuse ce qui est original
dans cette assiette c'est le délire un
peu un long fleuve d'ananas et
reconstituer dans l'assiette un petit
côté peut-être en fontang qui les fera
sourire bien
je des textures de croustillant de
moelleux de crémeux avait la petite
crème à côté c'est judicieux
la petite touche frites à côté et
beaucoup mieux que je pensais la seule
que j'ai mis vraiment la dernière minute
bon jean-françois ya une vraie cohérence
dans ce dessert il ya une émotion qui se
passe c'est cool ça c'est alors ya quand
même beaucoup d'actions à dans top chef
les aime bien dire nous on valorise les
prises de risque en vaut on veut
l'audace au final c'est vrai que on va
remettre la photo de ce décès à françois
visuellement assez dégueulasse on dirait
bien qu'on a craché dans la saison alors
ben c'est pas terrible et voulaient pas
voter non mais je goûte benjamin lagarde
m'avait invitée chez vous à dîner on a
dîné des nuggets ce qu'on ait fait
vibrer des migrants on a bouffé sait
recevoir
la mode c'est pour moi la moitié pour
mes chiens franchement c'est pas bien ce
qu'ils ont fait parce que là mais non mr
moi je sais pas cuisiner couper un
ananas tout le monde peut le faire il
après mais c'est vrai la gâteau un nom
mais il a eu accès c'est un ananas rôti
et fait reconstituer un il n'a pris
aucun risque alors qu'à une candidate il
était en dernière chance avec deux
candidates et on a éliminé une fille qui
avait pris un risque majeur son plat
était beau ils l'ont éliminé parce
qu'ils avaient des couteaux ils ont pas
trouvé ça bien mais elle avait pris un
risque
et franchement moi j'ai pas aimé du tout
parce qu'on a éliminé une femme et c'est
pas bien